Okay, so there's this
There's this "Spirit of Good", let's say
And what the Spirit of Good does is act in the world,
on the potential of the world,
to generate the actuality of the world.
And the Judeo-Christian proposition is,
is that if you confront the potential of the world,
with good in mind,
using truth
truthful communication
Then the order that you extract is good
And then that's echoed in Genesis,
when God is using the word
And he creates cosmos out of potential,
and every time he does that he says:
"And it was good"
Which is I think, it's so interesting because
There's a proposition there and the proposition is that
if you encounter potential with truth,
the cosmos you create is actually good
Well, that's
That's just an absolutely overwhelming idea! If it's true
If it's true, it's the greatest idea there ever was